a theatrically released movie that's
ultimately one part of a miniseries that
came out last year all right son of God
that's it sound more epic so no so son
of God is a movie that was part of that
Bible miniseries that came out last year
that took the Jesus parse took the
select scenes from it gave it a
theatrical release now we have a movie
that's about the life of Jesus Christ
and I was really skeptical about this
movie going into it I was like all right
part of a miniseries it's gonna feel
like it's made-for-tv and it does for
the most part but there were a couple of
things about this movie that I did like
what they did with it going into this
movie first and foremost I was hoping
they would touch on the fact as to why
people felt that this Jesus had to die
seriously a lot of these Jesus movies
gloss over that like it was Jesus and he
died because he had to salvation and
stove's magic I'm always left with that
feeling of know like politically
speaking why did they feel they had to
kill this guy and why was it such a big
deal of what went into it and this movie
actually to my surprise touched on that
very thing at first they kind of treat
him like Sega treated Sony in the mid
nineties alike that's you saying that's
a that's not a threat trust me it's it's
not a threat call me when you have some
important to tell me and in that same
situation the small annoyance grows into
a problem where they feel like they need
to deal with this I like that also the
portrayal of Jesus first of all I do
have to touch on this why can't
Hollywood actually give us a Jesus into
Jesus movie that's Jewish the whole
thing is Jesus was Jewish right so why
not make him chew it I want to see it
Jesus in a movie that looks like that
I'd be really cool it would break ground
people be like whoa you mean he doesn't
have long hair and he's not kind of
whitish with a Spanish name but his
portrayal of Jesus in this movie was
pretty good though I don't know about
you but before a certain time I think
before the Jeremy Sisto Jesus came out
which they made him really like hey
what's up guy says go yeah let's hang
out all the jesus' were these really
monotone guys are just like I had the
Son of God have you sitting there
running you're dead
monotone I'm boring I would think that
is Jesus it because thousands of
followers would be a charismatic guy it
wouldn't be so monotony wouldn't be so
boring like the fact that this Jesus
seemed wise because you he had all the
right answers to all these questions
people are trying to trip him up he's
like nope that he seemed humble yet he
seemed pretty personable he'd laugh and
joke with people it was fine it made him
human and relatable I like it when Jesus
is human and relatable however the movie
is made for TV this movie is one of two
things it's either a really impressive
made-for-tv movie or it's a not as
impressive theatrically released movie
you can tell the scope of this movie
isn't as big as they want it to feel and
when you do see a landscape shot of an
entire city it looks like standard death
I'm not lying to you what's watching it
like oh alright you guys thought that
was okay couldn't spend a few extra
bucks to make that look high-def in the
movies two hours and 20 minutes long I
was like this is gonna be a grind let's
watch the movie I was okay went by
pretty fast you don't feel like it's
long until you're driving home you're
like yeah that was a long movie however
a movie that's 2 hours and 20 minutes
long just covers the life of Jesus
himself you don't really know anything
about anyone else all the Apostles you
know very little about them 1 they
concentrate on more than the others
there's even the scene in passing Souls
like and by the way John the Baptist
died and they're all just torn up about
it like oh man he was a good friend he
was a good teacher too you're like I
never saw that guy who we see I mean if
you've read the book you know well if
you're just watching the movie you're
like I don't know why you guys cared I
don't know why I should care Brandon the
movies called son of God not entourage
so it should concentrate on Jesus I'm
just saying I would have liked to have
known more about the people around him
so the movie plays a few things smart
dude in the movie portrayed Jesus well
fact is is not the worst Jesus movie out
there I've seen it all by and large a
lot of them bore me to tears because I'm
like it's very informative guys thank
you the problem is why would you go buy
a movie ticket for this when you can buy
the entire miniseries comparatively
speaking for cheaper I mean it's more
expensive than a movie ticket but you
could a lot more with it however son of
God engaged me where I wanted to be
engaged and it played the angle I was
actually hoping it would play that I
didn't think it would play it still
feels like a made-for-tv movie for sure
especially in some scenes however I'll
still say son of God is a good time note
sacrament required because it's
alcoholic you get it so what is your
favorite Jesus story we're talking movie
it made-for-tv movie what
whatever it would be a comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more